all right for decades the United States
has been footing the bill for the safety
and the security of the European
continent and all while many of our
allies all across the Atlantic failed to
live up to their commitments now today
in Brussels President Trump made it
perfectly clear the US taxpayer is not
and no longer going to be Europe's ATM
machine take a look at this delinquent
states have to pay for them so if you go
back 10 or 20 years you just add it all
up its massive amounts of money is owed
Germany is just paying a little bit over
1% whereas the United States and actual
numbers is paying four point two percent
of a much larger GDP so I think that's
inappropriate also you know we're
protecting Germany were protecting
France we're protecting everybody and
yet we're paying a lot of money to
protect now this has been going on for
decades this has been brought up by
other presidents but other presidents
never did anything about it because I
don't think they understood it or they
just didn't want to get involved but I
have to bring it up because I think it's
very unfair to our country it's very
unfair to our taxpayers and I think that
these countries have to step it up not
over a 10-year period have to step it up
immediately now the president he's
absolutely right and even the Secretary
General of NATO is backing up President
Trump let's take a look at this we are
willing to discuss many important issues
on the side among them is defense
and we all agree that we have to do more
I agree with you that we have to make
sure that ours are investing more the
good news is that the Allies have
spotted invest more in defense of the
years of hunting defense purchased have
started to add billions to the defense
budgets and numbers don't lie so let's
do something the mainstream media would
never do we're gonna break down those
numbers now the North Atlantic Treaty
Organization or NATO it was first
utilized as a unified military deterrent
to the looming Soviet threat and to
provide inner continental stability
throughout Western Europe and North
America
it was formed after two world wars
actually devastated the European
continent it took the lives of hundreds
of thousands of American heroes now NATO
has a massive budget around a trillion
dollars now this year the United States
contributed over 700 billion dollars to
that budget
alright let's compare that to the rest
of our allies the next highest
contribution well that would come from
the United Kingdom
they only contribute sixty one point
five billion Germany a mere fifty 1
billion Canada comes in frankly at an
embarrassingly low 21 billion and the
country where NATO is headquartered
Belgium they contribute only five
billion dollars in fact the United
States you the American pact taxpayer
you're on the hook for 70% of NATO's
expenses now that's right you we pay 70
cents of every dollar that NATO spends
and while all NATO allies agreed to
contribute at least 2% of the country's
overall GDP to the NATO budget the u.s.
is only get this only one of four
nations to actually follow through on
that agreement and that standard the
United States actually contributes well
almost double three point five percent
of our massive GDP to NATO's budget and
meanwhile it's a much different story
among our allies take a look year's
green economic powerhouse Germany they
only contribute one point two four
percent
not the 2% and three Western European
countries
well they contribute less than even 1%
so that's right one country our country
we're proud of the United States of
America is now bearing the financial
burden of NATO and the protection of
Europe and North America while 27 other
countries sadly are laughing all the way
to the bank
so it's an item to the president's
leadership America he's putting them on
notice will no longer be the world's
piggy bank and our allies must pay their
fair share and of course this includes
the de facto leader of the EU Germany on
one of Europe's wealthiest nations fails
to properly fund NATO get this and the
president pointed this out today they're
spending billions of dollars in Russia
in order to support massive energy trade
deals in other words Germany they're not
going to adequately fund the protection
of their own country but they're more
than happy to prop up one of NATO's
so-called biggest threats the one they
keep telling us about the bad actor with
Putin in the bad country of Russia and
earlier today the president called out
the German Chancellor Angela Merkel for
her country's blatant double standard
it's about time take a look
said when Germany makes a massive oil
and gas deal with Russia yeah you're
supposed to be guarding against Russia
and Germany goes out and pays billions
and billions of dollars a year to Russia
I think that's very inappropriate and
the former Chancellor of Germany is the
head of the pipeline company that's
supplying the gas as ultimately Germany
will have almost 70 percent of their
country controlled by Russia with
natural gas so you tell me is that
appropriate and they would like been
complaining about this from the time I
got it it should have never been allowed
to have happened but Germany is totally
controlled by Russia because they were
getting from 60 to 70% of their energy
from Russia and a new pipeline and you
tell me if that's a
because I think it's not and I think
it's a very bad thing for NATO and I
don't think it should have happened
now Merkel responded with what was a
vague indirect frankly pathetic
statement lamenting the country's
history under Soviet control but now how
can someone possibly make the case that
Donald Trump is compromised by Russia or
Vladimir Putin he actually is urging
Merkel to get their energy from us the
United States of America and by the way
and their dependence on Russia now this
is a move that would literally
Russia's fragile economy and by the way
of Russia's economy falters Vladimir
Putin is finished so so much for all the
media conspiracies almost two years now
all the lies saying Donald Trump is
compromised by Vladimir Putin now
imagine how many just for a second high
paying career jobs could be created in
the United States of America if we would
get those billions and billions of
dollars and we were importing our
natural gas to Germany of which by the
way we have an abundance of more than we
can use in hundreds of years and as you
might imagine president Trump's his
tough talk in Brussels was met with
absolute predictable hysteria from the
mainstream media and of course their
best friends in the Democratic Party now
after spending 18 months warning us all
the sky is falling because of the fake
phony narrative the witch-hunt that
Donald Trump was somehow Vladimir
Putin's puppet the left is now in a
total freakout mode that Donald Trump
today used a lot of anti Russia rhetoric
and demanding that countries pay their
fair share and by the way that's
supposed to lead us now to catastrophe
you can't win with these people in other
words a typical Trump hating day in the
media with their Democratic allies and
as always we've got all the tape to
prove it take a look
it's a renewed Icarus demand that he's
making here the EU was meant to get
around and away from that toxic
nationalism right but who's bringing it
back Donald Trump America first is toxic
nationalism it is unprecedented language
it is a real threat to the Alliance it's
a threat to
the Democratic liberal post war world
order that Harry Truman himself signed
into into being with the NATO
declaration seventy years ago frankly
it's just infuriating to watch this
happen you cannot imagine any American
president all the way back 75 years
deciding to become the critic in chief
of NATO
I mean it's Orwellian it's infuriating
to see this happen its diplomatic mouth
and there's a lot more alright so think
of it this way you have the leaders of
the Democratic Party well they have no
vision for the country got Nancy Pelosi
Chuckie Schumer now remember their
agenda for 2018 is very very simple oh
they want their crumbs back they want to
impeach Trump but don't say it they want
open borders I want to keep Obamacare
and they don't want judge Cavanaugh on
the bench or any Trump choice anyway
they released a statement a joint
statement bashing trumpet said quote
president Trump's brazen insults and
denigration of America's most steadfast
allies Germany is an embarrassment
his behavior this morning is another
profoundly disturbing signal that the
president is more loyal to Russian
President Vladimir Putin than to our
NATO allies actually just the opposite
is true so okay what a Pelosi and
Schumer what are they afraid of Putin
why do they want to make Russia rich
again why so the American taxpayers all
of you are footing the bill for over 70%
of NATO liberals by the way they are so
generous with your money and by the way
why don't they encourage Germany to buy
our natural gas like the president is
it's important to remember this is all
coming from America's so-called elites
the very same people who think they know
best the same people who think giving
billions of dollars to Iran and the
mullahs in Iran that was a wonderful
idea it's gonna bring us peace in our
time the same people who thought bribing
North Korea as Bill Clinton tried in the
1990s would prevent them from building
nuclear weapons didn't work out that way
the same people actually cringe at the
thought of America again leading on the
world stage and the same people who
sadly but routinely looked down on you
us
we the American people remember you're
the irredeemable deplorable z'
you're the ones that cling to your Bible
your yeah you know to just be grossly
generalistic you could put half of Trump
supporters into what I call the basket
of deplorable 's right
the racist sexist homophobic xenophobic
Islamophobic you name it same playbook
will see it all throughout this election
year judge Calvin on his family will
experience nothing changes they don't
have any vision to make the country
better now in 2016 Peter struck text
that that he could actually smell Trump
voters in a rural Virginia Walmart he
can smell us
I like Walmart and just yesterday well
you have MSNBC conspiracy anchor thrill
up his leg Chris Matthews comparing
Trump supporters believe it or not take
it a step further untamed dogs you don't
believe me let's take a look he's taking
a Republican Party a grass his party
they'd spent 6070 years leading the war
in the Cold War hating the Russians for
how their aggressiveness in the world
and taking over countries on their
border and being tyrannical the way they
are now and he has those people cheering
against Western Europe was his liberal
and democratic and free market and
attacking them while saying how prompt
agreeing which Isis he's doing his best
it's remarkable the dog he's dog
training these people oh that's what
they really think of us now these same
elites in the media they're celebrating
the widespread anti Trump protests that
are gonna be taking place this week
throughout Europe one of the reasons
we're here and as we discussed last
night they're all forgetting you know
history does repeat itself remember
Ronald Reagan President Reagan faced the
same backlash same demonstrations before
his policy of peace through strength
trust but verify the evil empire tear
down this wall which spurred some of the
most historic diplomatic achievements in
world history President Trump could now
be poised to follow in those footsteps
we could all hope and we'll have more on
the president's trip throughout Europe
throughout the show but we do have other
important breaking news on the domestic
front
Trump aiding former FBI lawyer Lisa page
today did not comply with her subpoena
and flat-out refused to testify before a
closed-door session of Congress she
sounds a little like Hillary and earlier
today the House Judiciary Committee
Chairman Bob Goodlatte he voiced this
very important concern let's take a look
at this it does appear that Lisa page
apparently has something to hide she has
been in complete defiance of cooperation
with the House Judiciary Committee in
the Oversight and Government
for seven months now dating back to the
first letter we wrote to the Department
of Justice in December of last year
asking for appearance there have been
two subsequent letters and two subpoenas
issued for her appearance and she has
defied all of that now when she says
that she has not had ample time to
prepare that is belied by the pressure
also reacted today tweeted out quote
ex-fbi lawyer lisa page today defied a
house of representatives and issued
subpoena to testify before congress Wow
but is anybody really surprised together
with her lover FBI agent Peter struck
she worked on the rigged witch hunt
perhaps the most tainted and corrupt
case ever yeah the media ignores that
now the window is fast closing for Lisa
page she must either comply with the
subpoena by the way this happened to us
be in big trouble or she will face
serious legal consequences including a
contempt of Congress citation and
meanwhile her corrupt FBI boyfriend
Peter struck well he's still set to
testify in public tomorrow get ready
this hearing is going to be explosive we
will have full analysis and reaction to
Peter structs time in the hot seat
tomorrow if he shows up